foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video we will be discussing some of the
recent news surrounding HBO's new Game
of Thrones series House of the dragon as
I'm sure most of you already know HBO
has renewed House of the Dragon for its
second season already this was announced
almost immediately after its first
episode aired on HBO and HBO Max not
only were the ratings very high for the
first episode but it seems those numbers
are growing larger with each new episode
so it's no wonder HBO is already looking
ahead to House of the dragon's second
season earlier this week there were some
articles suggesting actress Elizabeth
Olsen might be joining House of the
Dragon next season as of right now most
fans know her for her work under
Marvel's giant umbrella but I actually
know her from a little movie named Win
River according to an article from
Winter iscoming.net the gossip started
when the website giant freaking robot
ran a story stating that Marvel star
Elizabeth Olsen is in early discussions
with HBO to join house on the dragon
second C season now this website doesn't
cite a reliable source such as variety
or Entertainment Weekly sites who are
known for often breaking this kind of
news but instead they mentioned that
this information is from one of their
own inside sources as of right now HBO
hasn't confirmed any of this a lot of
the fans on social media has run with
the story without it being confirmed by
the actress herself we wouldn't be so
fast to believe it as we mentioned
Elizabeth Olsen hasn't said anything
about this nor has anyone who works at
HBO since we're still so far away from
actually seeing House of the dragon's
second season they most likely wouldn't
want this news out there just yet anyway
so even if this is accurate I doubt we
will hear anything from HBO or Elizabeth
Olsen right now what I find even more
interesting than this is the other news
that's gaining Steam on the internet as
for the other breaking news surrounding
House of the dragon's second season many
fans are also saying The Witcher star
Henry Cavill will be joining the show
now for those of you who might not be
that familiar with the name Henry Cavill
he's is most known for his role in the
Man of Steel this isn't the only reason
why fans want to see him in a show
focusing on House Targaryen Henry is
also known for The Witcher series on
Netflix I think ever since fans saw
Henry donning the white blonde hair they
wanted to see him on the back of a
dragon in a new Game of Thrones series I
mean just have a look at this guy now I
love Matt Smith as much as the next fan
but when I think of Damon Targaryen I
think of someone like this his damn
jawline looks like it's made out of
stone now this is who should be riding
on the back of a dragon incinerating
cities all over Westeros when I hear
Rainier say targaryens are more like
Gods than men again I think of someone
like this who looks like an actual
superhero I think Henry would look
incredible as a member from House
Targaryen in House of the Dragon now the
only issue is I don't know who he would
be HBO has already found actors for
viserys Damon aegon aemond one eye and
many other targaryens who were alive
during the dance of the Dragons if they
did bring Henry and into the show I'm
not exactly sure what house he would be
from again none of this is confirmed
anyway but it's always fun to speculate
about these things now in other recent
news actress Natalie Emanuel who was
missande on Game of Thrones had
something to say about House of the
Dragon I know a lot of you like hearing
whenever the Game of Thrones actors have
something to say about the new show
have your final scenes yet and are you
happy with how
yes
best season ever
it's a little bit Avengers assembled
it's a little bit kind of like well that
was totally what season seven was all
about yeah
exactly character development
sorry
but it
I really need to shut up you're brave
oh my God
I couldn't let you go without asking you
a little question about Game of Thrones
sure
if you could describe the season finale
of Game of Thrones in one word
how would you describe that
the article says Natalie Emanuel who was
missande on Game of Thrones offers
advice to House of the Dragons actors
House of the Dragons HBO debut set a
record for the network and its streaming
service HBO Max their debut Drew
millions and millions of fans across
linear and streaming services leading to
a speedy renewal for its second season
while the series may have a long way to
go before matching the legacy of Game of
Thrones which essentially dominated
conversations around television and pop
culture in its later years this great
start indicates the drama could grow
into a juggernaut of its own that would
launch many of the House of the Dragons
actors into a higher level of Fame
leading to more opportunities and a more
fervent fan base that could be a lot to
adjust to since for some of the cast
this will mark their first roles on such
a global scale Emmanuel who was in Game
of Thrones for most of its run starring
as missande from season 3 until the
final season was asked by The Hollywood
Reporter what what advice she'd give to
House of the dragon's Ensemble the
actress says she hopes that the new show
is a big success and stresses the
importance of the cast sticking together
as a way of dealing with her Newfound
Fame in a statement down below she said
I'm sure they already know but this fan
base shoe they are passionate and they
are amazing and who knows how this
series will be received but I hope it's
a huge success and if it is it's an
experience and it will be an adjustment
for sure if you're not used to that
level of attention or recognition it's
definitely something so I guess my
advice would be just to enjoy it and
look to each other it was really
important that we as the group went
through all of that together and held
each other down in we as fans should
note that for as much controversy as the
Game of Thrones finale generated the
actors and actresses was mostly skilled
at keeping the focus on the storylines
and the characters now the fans could
disagree vehemently about the
storytelling decisions and they often
did but the focus remained largely on
the expansive adapted world of George RR
Martin's novels while it's still early
yet House of the dragon's Ensemble has a
good example to follow let me know what
all of you think about this down below
how many of you would actually like to
see Elizabeth Olsen or Henry Cavill on
the show next season do any of you
actually think they would be a good fit
and if so what character should they
fill I'm wondering what all of you think
as always I want to thank all of you for
watching my video I hope all of you have
a great day I will see you again very
soon bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign